it's funny isn't it we've got all this
technology all these clever machines
rules and schedules to organize
ourselves but when it comes down to it
it's just us
able to force ourselves to do something
but unable to force ourselves to
actually pay attention to the thing
the solution to the problem of getting
things done i'm told is more discipline
and habits which i'm sure works for most
people but as a medical student with a
bunch of other jobs i actually found
that when i went from this mainstream
scheduling advice which made me
absolutely miserable to a more elizabeth
chaotically organized schedule and just
doing things when it felt like a
reasonable time to do them my results
and happiness actually increased a lot
i've now realized i can get a lot more
done easier if i work alongside my brain
instead of forcing it to do things on an
arbitrary schedule which it absolutely
hates and punishes me for so if habits
also don't work for you and if your
current schedule is driving you nuts
today i'm going to be breaking down in
detail my brain's instinct with all of
the principles and the lines of
reasoning that i have built over years
of trying to successfully live a
chaotically organized life in the hope
that by the end of this video you can
also internalize all of the same
instincts and rethink the way that you
approach your schedule to be able to
succeed without habits in chaos i'm
going to use how i study in medical
school as an example and as detailed as
this may seem once it's internalized it
only takes a few seconds to apply let's
jump straight into it the very first
thing that i do before i even think of
working or scheduling is identifying and
introducing all of the tasks that i am
due to do to my brain and seeing how my
brain reacts to them in this way i can
see what sort of skills are required of
me when doing the task so i can figure
out what is the best version of me that
can show up for this task let me explain
what i mean even though studying in
medical school seems like one huge thing
it's obviously composed of so many
different sorts of studying and tasks
that i need to do and all of these
things will naturally for me fall into
some sort of category so i'm going to
list all of these things and i'm just
going to let my brain instinctively
group them and what tends to happen to
me for my studying is that they fall
under four categories reading writing
problem solving and physical practice
the reason that this is valuable is that
i can then evaluate how much attention
drive and energy is required for all of
the tasks in these different categories
so for example so the reading category
is something that requires relatively
low attention compared to everything
else that i need to do it also requires
low levels of drive because i'm likely
to want to do things here because
if i want to study the easiest thing i
can do realistically is just read
something about it it's quite fun and
also when it comes to energy it's very
low level energy i can do it lying in
bed before i go to sleep i can compare
this with writing for example which is
an activity which requires high levels
of attention i really really need to do
active work to get the task done also it
requires high levels of drive i usually
don't find writing essays or writing
projects or writing kind of studies and
research interesting i find it really
challenging and also it requires high
levels of energy just because it
requires so much motivation and work on
my end so i can see how any task that
falls in a category that requires little
attention little drive and little energy
is an activity that i'm likely to have
high levels of motivation to do on the
other end any tasks that requires high
levels of attention high levels of drive
and high levels of energy will be a task
that i will generally have low
motivation to do because it takes a lot
of work
so i will explain in a moment why this
categorization helps a lot when it comes
to scheduling but just now we can see
how this breakdown kind of adds color
and adds life and empowers my brain in
the way that it approaches work in
general because given a day where i have
for example low levels of motivation if
i thought of studying as one huge big
thing this level of motivation wouldn't
be enough to get it done however there
will always be tasks that require so
little energy or so little drive or so
little attention that means that they
fall under the amount of motivation that
is required and therefore i have enough
to do it and i'm actually enjoying and
able to do this activity so whenever i'm
approaching tasks i will kind of
categorize them in this way and see
therefore based on the attention drive
and energy that is required for them how
much motivation does this task require
of me and how much brain power does this
task require next i'm moving on to my
second point which is perhaps the most
important one of all for me and this is
basically understanding how my brain
conceptualizes time because not all time
off is made the same and it's not
appropriate or functional for me to just
book in something to work whenever i
have time off because i won't be able to
work that way the way that my brain
conceptualizes time or what's a good
time or a bad time to do something is
very much based on my energy and
motivation and therefore when i think of
scheduling or when i think of time in
general it's always done on a motivation
map and i'm going to show you how you
can do motivation mapping for yourself
it pays a lot in the future to
understand exactly how you work and how
your levels of motivation fluctuate
throughout the day week month year etc
etc i'm going to show you how i do this
for example i know that on a daily basis
i am not a morning person in the morning
my levels of motivation and energy tend
to be quite low i'm a night owl so as
the day progresses my levels of
motivation tend to increase and they
peak at around evening and night time
until obviously they crash because i i
need to sleep so this is how my levels
of motivation increase throughout the
day it's also important to realize here
that my self-restraint however goes down
throughout the day so what this means is
that i don't have the ability to force
myself to do things during the night
time so even though i have more energy
to do things then i can't force myself
to do things if i schedule something for
late at night i'm very likely to go ah
square i'll just do it tomorrow however
first thing in the morning or in the
early part of the day i'm able to do
tasks that i don't want to do a lot
easier even though i have a lot less
energy so what this means is for the
evening is a good time for me to do a
high energy task that i enjoy the
morning time is a good time for me to do
a low energy task which i hate and in
the midday or the early evening or as
soon as i finish my main obligations is
a good time for me to do a task which is
high energy which i don't enjoy so this
sort of motivation mapping throughout
the day is something that i always keep
in mind when i'm going to discuss what i
discuss later but this doesn't only
happen on a daily basis for example a
sunday night is not a good time for me
to work i have low levels of motivation
even though it's technically evening
time because i just think oh it's a new
week i deserve time off saturday is a
good time for me to work so kind of
thinking how these levels fluctuate
throughout the week but also very
importantly there are unique things that
will act as motivation boosters that i
am aware of so for example if i finish a
huge project let's say a youtube video i
know that once i finish a big task i get
a huge motivation boost in general in
life i just feel like i've accomplished
something and i'm happy so i know as
soon as i publish something the next day
is a good time for me to actually have
higher levels of motivation so i can put
in a task there that is more difficult
that i don't want to do or for example
when i do very well in something like an
exam or when i finish a semester and a
new semester starts or for example after
my birthday or when a new year starts or
a new season starts i know that i have
this renewed level of motivation
boosters which kind of fades in a few
days or weeks depending on how big the
thing is that happened but i know that i
am due these motivation boosters after
something good happens in my life now as
this motivation map is coming into life
one super important part of it is
putting in the real deadlines for what
i'm supposed to do so this for example
is when is the project due when is the
practice exam happening when is the
final exam happening when is the
academic year closing all of these
things will go in my calendar and these
will be the only things that i will put
in there as strict deadlines the reason
for this is that i'm creating little
motivational loops for example between
now and when my final exam is i know
that i will have a slowly increasing
which at some point will go exponential
motivation level to study for that exam
also i know if i have a project kind of
sooner i will have the same sort of
pattern like low motivation and it will
greatly increase as i go around it so i
know as i'm creating this little cycles
and bubbles of tasks that are due i know
that as i get closer to the task my
motivation for getting that task done
will increase with the anxiety of the
deadline increasing now i know that i
should not and very often actually now i
don't rely on that last minute
motivation to get things done but in the
back of my mind i always know that it is
there so worst case scenario i know that
i shouldn't feel too too bad if five
days before something is due i don't
feel like doing it because i know three
days later i'm going to want to do it a
lot more because my motivation is due to
increase as the task is due so these are
also things that i will add to my
motivation map now we move on to the
last stage as i said up to now
everything is instinctual nothing has
actually gone on to my schedule apart
from the strict deadlines but i have all
of the instincts to get things done on
one level i know all of the tasks that i
am due to do and what categories they
fall into what my levels of motivation
are for this task how much energy and
focus they will require what is the best
mindset that i can be in to do this task
on the other level i'm intimately
familiar with every day all of the free
time that will be available in my
calendar is time that also based on this
motivation mapping i know what my energy
will be at the time what my motivation
will be at the time kind of what's going
on in my life and how i'm emotionally
feeling around this time so basically
what i then do is that every single day
i will pick a task based on what the
motivation requirements and the energy
requirements for that task are and what
i'm feeling at the moment and what my
motivation map instinctively looks like
at the moment and so once i match these
with one another the only question i
need to ask myself is what's the best
thing for me to do right now and what do
i feel like doing right now and that's
what i will just sit down and do because
i am picking everything that i need to
do every single day i'm kind of avoiding
that pain of putting my brain into this
arbitrary regular schedule of things
because it has the freedom to pick what
it needs to do when it makes sense what
this also means is that then i am
guaranteeing that i am showing up as the
most motivated as the most focused as
the most excited version of myself to do
that task this is a very intelligent
elizabeth that shows up because when i
need to do things that do not match my
motivation at the moment that do not
match my energy at the moment i can show
up as a very slow bored annoyed
elizabeth that will not get this task
done properly which then means that the
difference between this arbitrary
schedule and this motivation mapped
schedule is night and day the results
that i get are absolutely so different
because i'm always working as my
motivated and focused version of myself
which doesn't need to stick to routines
which i hate because the deadlines are
always in the calendar i never forget or
skip them they are always done in time
and on a day-to-day basis i just do what
i feel like very often i do end up
falling behind on things but i have a
video where i explain my fall behind
catch up and go ahead schedule which is
definitely a good way to get things done
chaotically within these real frameworks
of real deadlines and also the end of
the day in the long term i'm showing up
as my focused and motivated version to
do most things an activity which
definitely requires low levels of energy
drive and attention to do and therefore
i do not need a lot of motivation to
make myself do is improving on my
logical and problem-solving skills and
generally making myself a better thinker
through brilliant which are very kindly
sponsoring this video i definitely think
that there are compounding benefits in
my problem solving and thinking skills
and especially the way that i approach
learning in general i think has changed
ever since i've started to use brilliant
at the moment i am doing the new course
on everyday maths because surprisingly
unsurprisingly i very much enjoyed doing
more complicated maths in school than
the pure basics i definitely think the
broader principles behind how brilliant
to create lessons and do teaching is
something that i try to apply myself
when i'm teaching myself things in
medicine so if you also want to have a
look at brilliant there will be a link
in my description that will give you 20
off but otherwise if you made it so far
thank you so much for spending this time
with me i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day be count yourself and others
and don't believe everything you think
thanks bye